bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
nous sommes en direct et celui qui nous
accompagne ce soir fait Étienne Klein
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin vous êtes physicien professeur
Océa le Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique mais aussi au NRJ alternatives
philosophe des sciences également vous
publiez court-circuit chez Gallimard
c'est un plaidoyer pour casser les murs
qui séparent encore les disciplines la
physique et la philosophie la culture
scientifique et la culture populaire
pourquoi faut-il les faire dialoguer ses
disciplines vous nous le direz tout à
l'heure dans la deuxième partie mais on
va commencer ce soir par Wagner cette
société russe privée de mercenaires qui
sévit notamment en Ukraine les députés
français ont adopté à l'unanimité une
résolution pour la classer parmi les
organisations terroristes un symbole
mais avec quel effet concret le chef de
Wagner Evgeni Prigogine défi une
nouvelle fois Moscou en ce jour
anniversaire des commémorations du 9 mai
Wagner dans la ligne de mire c'est notre
grand débat dans un instant sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver à 20h15 les
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
dans Bourbon Express ce soir ce drapeau
européen que l'opposition ne veut plus
voir voilà pour le menu vous me suivez
Étienne ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et si c'était lui après Poutine bien sûr
l'homme le plus puissant de Russie
Ève gueny prigogne le chef de la société
militaire privée Wagner n'en finit pas
de défier Moscou encore aujourd'hui en
ce 9 mai il accuse les autorités russes
d'être incapables de défaire l'Ukraine à
la raquaux ajoute-t-il et peut-on
l'arrêter bonsoir Thomas gesillou et
merci d'être là vous êtes députés
renaissance du Rhône vous êtes président
de la Commission de la Défense à
l'Assemblée et vous avez voté avec
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale à l'Assemblée cette résolution
on va y revenir bonsoir Marie Madras
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
politologue au CNRS et professeur à
Sciences Po grande spécialistes de la
Russie Vincent Huges bienvenue bonsoir
chronique régulier dans cette émission
grand reporter et spécialiste de Wagner
qui tissent sa toile en Afrique
spécialiste de l'Afrique ou Wagner
artiste sa toile précisément enfin
bonsoir Céline Bardet bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes juriste et
enquêtrice criminelle internationale
spécialisés dans les crimes de guerre
Étienne Klein le retour de la guerre en
Europe vous l'évoquez donc court-circuit
alors n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez ou même interroger nos
invités on va commencer par planter le
décor Wagner et son chef qui est
evegaini prigogi il a 200 secondes c'est
un défi c'est black au top chrono c'est
parti
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
toutes et tous on vous accueillir du
vôtre de votre estrade alors nous
parlons d'un homme qui pendant de
nombreuses années ne voulaient surtout
pas qu'on parle de lui et d'ailleurs
c'était assez réussi puisque le nom
d'eph Gunny pris goji ne faisait pas
souvent la une des journaux mais ça
c'était avant la guerre en Ukraine parce
que regardez début de l'année moi
janvier à la Une de Paris Match avec
cette photo qui remonte à 2011 quand on
le surnommait encore le cuisinier de
Poutine donc pour résumer son parcours
pris gojin c'est un malfrat de un truand
de Saint-Pétersbourg qui est sorti en 90
de prison puis le moment où l'URSS
s'écroule et donc dans ce Far West avec
des méthodes de la pègre il a acheté un
petit restaurant puis un plus grand ou
Poutine est devenu un habitué il avait
les réseaux il a eu les contrats et
voilà qu'il est devenu oligarque donc ce
qui est surprenant c'est que pendant
très longtemps trigogine restait dans
l'ombre et il voulait surtout pas
reconnaître son rôle influent et puis là
depuis que la guerre en Ukraine regardez
il rebondit qu'au contraire ses resp
possibilité il se présente comme le
troll en chef de la Russie notamment
dans la manière dont ils ont cherché
influencer les élections américaines et
puis ce qu'il avait longtemps nié il
reconnaît qu'il est le patron du groupe
Wagner qui permet à la Russie d'un
intervenir officieusement alors ça a été
au Dombasle en 2014 en Syrie en 2015
maintenant en Afrique j'imagine que vous
allez un peu revenir sur tout ça alors
le changement c'est que maintenant il
est passé donc de l'ombre pardon à la
lumière vous allez peut-être nous
expliquer pourquoi ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que en ce moment il tape à bras
raccourci sur la Méru l'armée russe en
janvier par exemple donc début de
l'année il revendiquait l'avoir pris la
ville de soledar alors que l'armée elle
en était incapable donc il critiquait
évidemment Moscou avait tenté un peu
d'apaiser en disant non il n'y a aucune
distension entre Wagner les mercenaires
et l'armée officielle bon aujourd'hui il
y a des distances qui apparaissent au
grand jour tous les jours une vidéo
contre l'armée russe en occitan
nommément chez Hugo qui est donc le
ministre de la Défense guirassimov le
chef d'état-major des armées en écoute
alors évidemment il y avait sans doute
de manière tu délicate d'épargner
Poutine que d'employer ces termes mais
il en a quand même rajouté une couche
puisque ce matin il a carrément accusé
l'armée russe d'avoir fuit le combat à
bakhmoud une partie de l'armée russe
pendant que c'est mes mercenaires à lui
tenait face aux Ukrainiens alors c'est
vraiment d'avoir dit ça pile le jour où
Poutine était sur la Place Rouge face à
l'armée russe pour leur dire mon dieu ce
que vous êtes de braves soldat on écoute
rien n'est plus important que votre
tâche militaire la sécurité du pays
repose sur vous l'avenir de notre état
et de notre peuple dépend de vous vous
accomplissez votre devoir militaire avec
honneur vous vous battez pour la Russie
bref on croit comprendre que ça tangue
un peu au sommet en Russie mais c'est la
question est à quel jeu je joue pris
gojine là vous avez des experts ça tombe
bien parce que moi j'ai pas bien compris
en fait
on va la poser tout de suite à
marie-mandra cette cette question on a
l'impression que Prigogine peut tous
permettre y compris faire du chantage à
l'état-major russe comment vous analysez
cette stratégie là
c'est un théâtre absolument sordide vous
vous rendez compte de ce qui se passe
cette guerre a été commencée il y a 15
mois presque Poutine dit encore ce matin
que ce n'est qu'une opération militaire
spéciale et que ce sont nous les
ukrainiens et tous les Occidentaux
sataniques qui avons commencé la guerre
pour détruire la Russie donc on est
toujours dans ce discours absolument
dément d'inversion des rôles c'est à
dire que si vous relisez le discours de
Poutine de ce matin
et vous mettez Russie à la place des
Occidentaux et l'Ukraine tout est vrai
c'est-à-dire le comportement
nazi la violence avoir lancé l'agression
la guerre c'est impressionnant donc
inversion accusatoire donc on est face à
un certain nombre d'individus qui sont
hors des réalités et qui sont vraiment
dans une sorte de de tripes
paranoïa que il y a beaucoup de démence
et de déraison
ils sont tous
ils sont tous les uns contre les autres
puisque ils ne savent plus que vous le
chef
le chef est de plus en plus affaibli et
ça ça prend un petit peu de temps de
l'expliquer mais clairement il est en
train de de perdre tous ses paris
Poutine en ce moment et nous ne sommes
pas face à un gouvernement qu'on nous
disons le ministre de la Défense
monsieur
parlementaire tout ça c'est du pipeau
nous sommes face à un système de plus en
plus militarisé et criminalisée et
Prigogine en est le meilleur exemple
c'est un criminel aujourd'hui le régime
poutinien est criminel d'ailleurs nous
en parlerons tout à l'heure quand nous
parlerons justement des de la poursuite
de la justice internationale la décision
de la France ils ont vu ces vidéos de
prix gaugine en rage contre l'état-major
est-ce qu'elle elles sont diffusées ces
images par la par la propagande à la
télévision Vincent et jeux
elles sont diffusées ce qu'on appelle
des chaînes telegram c'est-à-dire des
chaînes qui sont généralement animées
par ce que l'on nomme les blogueurs
militaires qui sont en règle générale
moitié journalistes moitié combattants
et souvent d'ailleurs plus volontaire
pour le front que analyse froid
et pertinent et en revanche les grands
rendez-vous notamment animé par le poète
de cours favori du Kremlin le dénommé
solo VF
évoque parfois prégogène mais évite
d'ouvrir le robinet à investir à l'image
de ce qu'on vient de voir à l'instant
vous savez en gros ce personnage me
conforte dans une conviction ancienne
que j'ai déjà déployée sur ce plateau à
savoir que dans certains cas la
psychanaly la psychanalyse est plus
performante que la science politique
l'intérêt de prégogène c'est le complexe
d'Icare il incarne c'est quelqu'un
Stéphane le rappeler à l'instant à juste
titre qui en fait à cultiver un profil
d'homme de l'ombre très longtemps et qui
tout d'un coup c'est surexposé à la
lumière des médias et il s'est approché
du soleil du pouvoir et comme Ikar il
risque de s'y brûler les ailes parce que
n'oublions pas que s'il fait preuve de
beaucoup d'audace dans ces haangs
anti-institution c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui n'a pas manifesté sa supériorité
baroute ça devait être c'est lui qui le
disait d'ailleurs la vitrine de son
avantage comparatif par rapport à ses
bras cassés
hors qu'en est-il aujourd'hui il ne
parvient toujours pas à prendre bermout
et je termine sur un constat qui me
paraît être l'un des phénomènes les plus
stimulants intellectuellement de ce
conflit c'est que en réalité d'ordinaire
vous avez les mercenaires au passage
ça sa société Wagner n'a pas d'existence
légale au regard du droit russe pourvu
qu'il existait à un droit russe peu
importe mais si vous voulez en général
l'État pas recourir au mercenaires la
France l'a fait Bob Denner par exemple
pour les bases besognes bon là on
assiste non pas à une sorte de
normalisation des milices au sein de
l'armée mais à une milicienisation de
l'armée on a quand même au stade où la
grande et Sainte Russie sous-traitent
une guerre absurde une guerre
d'agression à des chaînes bon avec un
cadirof qui a islamisé la Tchétchénie
avec la valve de Moscou et avec des
reprises de justice qu'on est allé
chercher 42000 quand même d'après les
services enseignements occidentaux dans
les cours des colonies évidentielles de
beaucoup sont morts
et la bataille de Marco qui sont sous le
le chapeau Wagner beaucoup sont morts ou
blessés 77%. 77 reddition des versions
Washington c'est un chiffre
d'aujourd’hui Thomas gassillou bon c'est
difficile de savoir à quoi joue votre
trigogine précisément mais il n'accuse
pas Poutine ça veut dire quoi ça à votre
avis ça sert ou ça dessert Poutine de
s'en prendre à son état-major et de
dénoncer des responsables aussi proches
de lui je pense que il faut parler avec
extrêmement de précaution d'une part moi
je suis partagé entre qualifier ça de
folie ou de stratégie que l'on ne
comprend pas et par ailleurs je sais que
les Russes évacuées en particulier sont
champions de la désinformation donc si
j'essaie de comprendre
qui aujourd'hui est un chef militaire
aculé qui a des piètres résultats qui
déjà doit se justifier auprès de ses
troupes en accusant un autre donc voilà
une première hypothèse deuxième
hypothèse c'est peut-être quelqu'un qui
a une feuille de route personnelle aussi
d'accession au pouvoir remplacer Poutine
ou accéder à d'autres responsabilités
par rapport à ceux qui critiquent et
troisième point on est peut-être même
dans une orchestration avec Poutine qui
peut être motivé par plusieurs raisons
depuis le début
la Russie de dire nous ne sommes pas
Wagner Wagner n'est pas représentant de
la Russie donc en affichant finalement
une dissension on déresponsabilise la
Russie par rapport à Wagner que ce soit
en Ukraine ou dans d'autres théâtres par
ailleurs dernière piste possible Poutine
se rend presque plus acceptable en
faisant planer le spectre d'une
accession au pouvoir de d'une personne
comme Prigogine vis-à-vis du reste de la
danse d'ombre il est fréquent pour
Poutine même de dénoncer des
responsables qui travaillent avec lui
donc finalement c'est pas forcément
dommageable à Poutine et donc soyons
très prudents sur ce qui se passer
réellement dans ce champ bien sûr Céline
Bardet Wagner c'est le pire du pire on
l'a on l'a bien compris des hommes qui
qui font la guerre au détriment complet
du droit du droit élémentaire de la
guerre du respect des civils du respect
des femmes bah oui totalement parce que
toute façon il se considère déjà ils ont
pas d'existence légale à proprement
parler et on est dans le mercenaria mais
après moi je pense que ce qui pousse
aussi prix que gojin c'est que
effectivement sur backmood qui galèrent
un peu c'est difficile mais Wagner en
attendant a quand même déployé dans le
monde et dans beaucoup de pays d'Afrique
mais aussi ils sont intervenus au
Venezuela aux Soudan etc ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est devenu une
institution de mercenaires en tout cas
une voix privée qui a quand même un
pouvoir important qu'un pouvoir
financier important puisque il se
servent sur les mines et les ressources
notamment des pays africains qui puisent
dans les ressources mais qu'il est
financent principalement c'est Poutine
qui finance Wagner
les munitions oui là les munitions sont
arrivées selon au dire de prigognes à
barmouth donc est-ce que c'est gagné
pour lui c'est efficace cette pression
le vrai pactole de la maison Wagner il
se trouve effectivement en Afrique le
type de contrats qui sont passés avec
notamment les jantes de type malienne
par exemple c'est en gros ces pays étant
dépourvu de cash c'est vous nous laissez
faire et en contrepartie nous jouissons
de la concession de tel gisements
orifères diamantifère etc un pays dont
on parle beaucoup depuis quelques temps
trop peu auparavant le Soudan dès 2017
Wagner s'installe au Soudan et vous avez
l'un des hommes liges de Prigogine qui
s'appelle Mirail potetkine qui pactise
avec asseoir qui est une société
soudanaise contrôlée par le
renseignement militaire local et ça lui
donne la possibilité via une société
nommée meroegole de mettre la main sur
plusieurs mine d'or du Soudan il se paye
sur la bête partout
avant de regarder ce qui s'est dit dans
l'hémistique puisque c'est rare pour une
fois l'unanimité était au rendez-vous
les renseignements font bien leur
travail sur Wagner on a l'impression que
beaucoup d'informations viennent des
Américains on sait ce qui se passe la
France connaît les agissements au plus
près de ces groupes paramilitaires moi
je pense que les non renseignements sont
bien informés vous savez que l'assemblée
on a une délégation parlementaire
mentionnément qui est couvert par le
secret défense donc bien j'en fais
partie bien entendu je peux pas être
exhaustif sur le sur le sujet mais nous
renseignements sont sont bien informés
notamment la DGSE la DRM pour deux
services spécialisés mais bien entendu
ne peuvent pas délivrer l'ensemble des
informations dont tu es disposent pour
des questions de sécurité nationale
pour combattre donc des criminels mais
c'est aussi des sociétés de sécurité de
la désinformation c'est tout un réseau
d'activités en République centrafricaine
Wagner c'est un état parallèle qui va
même jusqu'à prélever l'impôt qui va
mettre la main sur des sociétés qui
fabriquent de la bière par exemple ou
d'autres éléments et qui mettent qui
devient quasiment une organisation
politique et militaire en parallèle de
les politiques aussi politique sur
infiltrées au plus haut niveau de l'État
pour influer sur l'ensemble que ce soit
de côté exécutif côté parlementaire
c'est envisageable possible
à la marge moi je n'en ai jamais croisé
séquences souvenir personnel en 2018 je
travaillais pour L'Express à l'époque et
alerté par des amis Bangui soit donc des
confrères centrafricains je vais
travailler sur l'implantation de la RCA
qui sera avec le Soudan la tête de pont
du retour en force non pas de l'éruption
mais du retour de la Russie poste
soviétique en Afrique et effectivement
c'est là qu'on mesure très vite que ça
n'est pas que du mercenaria et de
l'armement mais confrères me raconte
quel est le barème un édito francophone
dans la presse locale c'est autant un
reportage à la gloire d'une initiative
de la l'ambassade de Russie c'est autant
c'est eux qui financent une radio la
restauration de larabilisation de ces
locaux c'est eux qui financé mise Bangui
2018-2019 via une de leur société locale
et donc c'est vrai qu'on a toujours
tendance à focaliser sur la dimension
militaire mais c'est aussi formidable
machine de guerre d'influence via des
médias via des fermatrol avec les
réseaux sociaux etc et par exemple on
retrouve dans les financeurs de Kémi
Séba Nathalie Yam donc ils sont un peu
les caricatures de l'influence
francophone à la solde de la Russie on
retrouve prigogne alors comment se sont
positionnés précisément les différents
groupes parlementaires unanimité je vous
le disais dans l'hémicycle pour classer
parmi les organisations terroristes la
liste est fixée par l'Union européenne
ce groupe Wagner regardez c'est un sujet
de Marco pommier
le groupe Wagner est-il un groupe
terroriste à l'image de daesh ou
d'Al-Qaïda l'assemblée a répondu oui à
l'unanimité Benjamin Haddad à l'origine
de la résolution estime que l'activité
du groupe paramilitaire russe répond à
la définition européenne du terrorisme
les membres du groupe Wagner ne sont pas
des simples mercenaires attirés par la
pas du gain il poursuivent une stratégie
globale du Mali à l'Ukraine de soutien à
la politique d'agression du régime de
Poutine contre nos démocraties Benjamin
Haddad a aussi dénoncé la naïveté du
rassemblement national sur la Russie
toutes les positions opportunistes que
vous afficherez aujourd'hui ou demain
tous les retournements de vestes ne
feront oublier à personne votre
indulgence coupable pendant des années
retournement de vestes ou pas le
rassemblement national a apporté son
soutien au texte de la majorité tout en
dénonçant une résolution avant tout
symbolique
cette résolution révèle donc du symbole
nous connaissons tous leur importance
mais le symbole ne fait pas l'action mes
chers collègues pour faire reculer le
groupe Wagner en Afrique où la Russie
nous mène une guerre d'influence les
résolutions ne nous aiderons guère à
gauche socialiste écologiste et
communiste ont apporté leur soutien à la
résolution
idem pour la France insoumise une
incertitude pesée sur le vote du groupe
les insoumis qui ont quand même dénoncé
une condamnation à géométrie variable
elles sont toutes dans le viseur de la
justice pour des crimes de guerre de ce
fait nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi
seul Wagner doit être inscrite sur la
liste européenne des organisations
terroristes 331 voies pour aucune
abstention consensus à l'Assemblée sous
les yeux de l'ambassadeur ukrainien
voilà qui est très attentif
marie-mendras à ce vote on est dans le
symbole non non c'est un vote important
c'est très très important surtout à
l'unanimité et d'autant plus que
d'autres Parlement nationaux prennent
des résolutions similaires que le
Parlement européen aussi votre
résolution sur résolution
condamnant les méthodes russes et
soutenant de plus en plus l'Ukraine il y
a aussi des résolutions au Conseil de
l'Europe au Nations Unies tout ça ce
sont des avancées et bien sûr c'est
absolument fondamental je crois
aujourd'hui
que nos états nos sociétés nos
organisations multilatérales disent
écrivent face voter ce qui est essentiel
c'est que ce qu'ils font et criminels
alors que ce soit terroriste criminel
enfin l'important c'est d'expliquer
qu'ils fonctionnent hors du droit dans
une violence extrême contre absolument
tout à la fois société être humain état
système politique élection donc il faut
de la déstabilisation
générale
au prix de leur propre hommes
c'est-à-dire que ce sont quand même
majoritairement des Russes qui meurent
qui sont blessés et on leur propose
quelques milieux et de d'euros pour
aller combattre mais on leur fait signer
que ils ont quand même une chance sur
deux de par revenir enfin c'est
absolument épouvantable et donc je je
pense que ça nous permet pour faire
avancer nos gouvernements nos opinions
publiques et nos résolutions et notre
droit d'aller tous dans le même sens et
qui il n'y a plus de droit en Russie
Thomas je vais vous faire réagir à
évidemment cette ce vote à l'unanimité
ses conséquences mais on vient de
l'apprendre par l'AFP un journaliste
français Harmon soldat peut-être vous le
saviez de l'AFP
a été tué lors d'une frappe de Rocket
dans l'est de l'Ukraine non loin de
marmotte quelle est votre réaction
on voit que les journalistes sont les
premiers exposés malheureusement à la
guerre qu'ils ont un devoir extrêmement
important de faire connaître ce qui se
passe sur place à deux heures d'avion de
Paris mais que malheureusement cette
fonction est très risquée et notamment
dans des dans des zones de guerre donc
on bien entendu on a des pensées pour la
famille de ce journaliste on pense à
l'ensemble de la communauté des des
journalistes qui font leur travail du
mieux qui peuvent mais qui
malheureusement sont aussi exposés à des
risques importants revenons à cette
résolution peut-être d'accord avec Marie
mandraz finalement ça reste essentiel ce
genre de vote pourtant quand on regarde
l'effectivité normative d'un tel vote on
se dit il faut que les 27 inscrivent sur
la liste organisation terroriste et il y
a Victor barne proportine le président
de la Hongrie qui ne votera pas à quoi
ça sert la première vocation me
semble-t-il le rôle du politique en
temps de guerre c'est de désigner
l'ennemi déjà et avec cette résolution
on dit clairement que Wagner est une
organisation terroriste et vous on
traite pas pareil une entreprise de
défense d'une organisation terroriste y
compris avant tout pour l'action
nationale puisqu'on a des leviers contre
Wagner certains qu'on peut avouer
d'autres qu'on peut moins avouer le
deuxième point c'est d'envoyer un
message politique extrêmement fort à nos
partenaires à la Russie dont Wagner est
un proxy et à ceux qui voudraient
travailler avec Wagner en disant que
pour nous clairement Wagner et une
organisation au terroriste et puis le
dernier point c'est bien entendu d'agir
dans le sens d'une inscription sur les
listes européennes des organisations
terroristes donc effectivement c'est une
décision qui doit se prendre en européen
mais la France espère ainsi enclencher
un mouvement et aboutira cette décision
sachant que je précise que il y a
également une liste à l'échelle de l'ONU
des Nations Unies mais qu'elle
malheureusement la Russie est en droit
de véto c'est une démarche qui aurait
peu de chance de prospérer Céline Bardet
vous qui êtes enquêtrice sur les crimes
de guerre sur des crimes internationaux
ce genre de vote fertiles à quelque
chose en préparant cette émission on
peut s'étonner qu'aucun mandat d'arrêt
international n'était pris par la CPI la
Cour pénale internationale contre elle
gagner Prigogine alors qu'il y en a un
pour Poutine oui oui je pense que ce
sont des choix stratégiques après là je
veux quand même dire que c'est important
cette résolution en France parce que
politiquement c'est posé quelque chose
donc c'est important il y a d'autres
pays qui l'ont fait la Lituanie la
Lettonie etc ok après ça reste
symbolique au sens où oui il n'y a pas
d'effectivité mais je pense qu'on verra
ce qui est très important c'est de
prendre conscience de l'importance de
Wagner et là je rejoins ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure qui est vraiment
une une entreprise qui touche à plein de
choses et dont c'est très difficile de
voir quelle est la stratégie de prix
d'origine et je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention mais il faut pas oublier
que légal ou pas légal etc toute
personne qui commet des crimes
internationaux et redevable et peut être
poursuivi que ce soit Prigogine ou ces
hommes donc compris dans les pays qui
n'ont pas signé la convention qui crée
la CPI la Convention de Rome comme la
Russie ou même l'Ukraine alors la Cour
pénale internationale peut décider de
poursuivre les crimes commis par des
membres de Wagner sur le territoire
ukrainien puisqu'elle est compétente
pour ça donc ça elle pourrait le faire
est-ce qu'elle va le faire c'est que si
Prigogine étendu crème on peut l'arrêter
ah bah oui de toute façon si pris goji
est en Ukraine on peut l'arrêter je
pense que les Ukrainiens je regarde ont
très envie de le faire mais je pense
qu'il doit pas être
identifiable aussi facilement que ça
mais ce que je veux simplement dire
c'est qu'il faut pas oublier que voilà
le droit la Cour pénale internationale
c'est un droit pénal individuel on
poursuit des individus et tous ces
individus qui respectent pas le droit
peuvent être poursuivis maintenant ça va
être intéressant de voir effectivement
ce que la Cour pénale internationale
pourrait faire parce que je pense que
c'est un problème dont il faut qu'on se
saisisse et pas seulement pour l'Ukraine
aussi pour tout ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays et la dernière chose que je
rajoute pardon quand même juste pour
clarifier c'est que l'Union européenne a
pris des sanctions contre Wagner dès
2020 et de et d'autres entrepr
d'ailleurs sur les avoir des oligares
sur les flux financiers qui Wagner
exactement et donc sont des sanctions
financières des restrictions de voyage
etc et des sanctions aussi l'année
d'après sur la question des crimes
commis dans les pays africains
de veto sur les sanctions entre la
Russie depuis 2014 donc je crois qu'il
faut pas trop trop focaliser sur Victor
Orban très bien ce sujet
vous nous trouvais à la hauteur contre
Wagner la discrétion de la cour
pénétrationnelle donc qui siège à La
Haye au Pays-Bas en la matière me plonge
dans une abyssale perplexité le premier
condamné de la CPI 2012 s'appelle Thomas
loubanga c'est un chef de ministre de la
République démocratique du Congo depuis
17 ans on recherche le patron un certain
Joseph Koni d'une des milices des
rébellions les plus cruelles de ce bas
monde qui s'appelle l'Armée de
résistance du Seigneur lorsque vit
notamment en Ouganda et dans les
pays voisins donc CONI échappé à en
revanche un de ces lieutenant qui
s'appelle Dominique angouen a été
condamné en février 2021 et là je vais
verser de l'auto-césine dans ces pays
n'a pas besoin de réunir un consensus
planétaire pour donc très franchement je
m'étonne par rapport notamment à ses
vidéos qui ont été documentées et
confirmées d'exécution sommaire parfois
d'une barbarie assez effente bon je
connais un peu les procédures j'ai
travaillé sur l'ACPI il m'est arrivé
d'être entendu pour des pré-êtes ou des
enquêtes etc donc je sais bien que tout
ça est lourd tout ça est long etc mais
franchement il y a de quoi la matière
est là Etienne Klein votre regard vous
n'êtes pas spécialiste mais ça interroge
vous disiez c'est effrayant tout à
l'heure en découvrant les images de pris
goji ne vous parlez un peu dans votre
livre de ce retour de la guerre en
Europe que Michel Serres auquel vous
rendez hommage ce philosophe des
sciences croyait encore possible malgré
l'après deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était dans notre sang et qu'on ne
pourrait jamais s'en débarrasser alors
que moi je lui disais mais non en Europe
en tout cas on exclut la possibilité de
guerres détails parce qu'on a pris des
mesures les institutions réagit la
barbarie notamment de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et non non toute paix est une
entre de guerre est une
entre-deux-guerre
des motivations de ce monsieur priogi il
y a plusieurs hypothèses mais on sent
que il peut lui avoir des motivations
mais la question que je voudrais vous
poser c'est quels sont les motivations
de ceux qui rejoignent ces bataillons en
sachant j'imagine que le taux de perte
écolossale et que ils ont très peu de
chance de revenir intacts
pour ceux qui nous regardent la plupart
sont d'anciens détenus qu'on a libéré à
la va-vite pour aller au front à la
boucherie à ensuite ils sont lavés de
toute condamnation la présence c'est
quand même mieux que la mort mais c'est
parce qu'ils disent
c'est parce qu'ils disent on a beaucoup
de retour quand même d'hommes qui ont
été il faut savoir que nous avons
beaucoup d'informations
du fait que les Russes armés ou Wagner
ne se préoccupe pas beaucoup de leur
blesser ou tuer sur le champ de bataille
surtout au début les Ukrainiens avaient
fait beaucoup de prisonniers qui ont
parlé
et la façon d'ailleurs dont il traite
leurs hommes qu'ils soient soldats
conscrit mercenaires officiers en dit
long sur la nature de ce régime que ce
soit des hommes payés par de l'argent
salle de prégogi nous payer par un état
voyou qu'elle est à russe donc
vous n'imaginez pas
la misère humaine
de ces individus de la vie qu'ils ont eu
de ce qu'ils vivent en prison et donc
quand on leur dit tu peux sortir là dans
une heure on te donne de l'argent et tu
veux va te battre tu vas être un héros
mais on peut pas t'assurer que tu en
sortiras vivant mais on peut t'assurer
que tu ne seras plus jamais en prison et
qu'une certaine somme ira à ta famille
c'est convaincant il faut rappeler
d'ailleurs que certains sortent de
prison qu'ils ont tué ou qu'ils ont
menacé certaines personnes leurs femmes
ou autre et arrivent comme ça et très
bonne ambiance une fois dans la société
russe je voudrais qu'on termine par
l'Afrique je voudrais vous faire
commenter une carte et je vous donnerai
la parole Thomas gacillou qu'on a
préparé sur la présence de Wagner en
Afrique Vincent eugeux alors
officiellement on l'a dit Wagner des
prisons nulle part mais il y a quand
même une certitude sur la présence de
ces commandos dans beaucoup de pays
est-ce que vous pouvez nous la commenter
entre ce que l'on sait sur le croit
savoir les points d'appui les plus
fructueux de Wagner sont effectivement
donc on l'évoquait soudain République
centrafricaine
Mali Libye sous dans du Sud et
Madagascar dans l'ingérence électorale
et l'ont fait en 2018 ils sont en train
de le refaire en 2023 le Mozambique est
à cas intéressant parce que Wagner a
contracté là-bas pour essayer de venir à
bout d'une sorte de filiale djihadiste
dans le Cabo Delgado la région du nord
du Mozambique qui sont pris une raclée
et ce sont des Sud-Africains qui sont
substitués donc Wagner n'est pas une
force invincible bon parce qu'en plus on
a un problème de main d'oeuvre il
recrute à tour bras parce qu'ici une des
contrats partout et ils ont pas
nécessairement des types à la à la
hauteur les services d'enseignement
occidentaux estiment que Wagner est
présent sous une forme ou une autre par
exclusivement militaire dans 15 à 20
pays d'Afrique je ne parle pas que de
l'Afrique et on pourrait évoquer évident
la Syrie le Venezuela était question
tout à l'heure à juste titre pour donner
un exemple très simple au Mali
nos services considèrent qu'il y a un
contingent relativement stable de 1000 à
1200 wagneriens musiciens comme ils
adorent s'appeler eux-mêmes la compagnie
qui sont présents au Mali et puis vous
avez derrière ces pays je m'arrête
là-dessus vous avez toute une autre
série de pays dans lesquels il y a les
officiers dans cette voile couleur kaki
des wagneriens pour essayer de les
convaincre c'est le cas du Burkina Faso
qui lui-même est aujourd'hui dirigé par
une agente militaire vous avez le
phénomène classique on évasse les
Français on dénonce le cas échéant les
accords de coopération militaires et
puis on fait venir Wagner dont la
performance n'a pas été éblouissante
pour terminer deux petites questions
Céline Bardet en Afrique là où Wagner
est présent est-ce que la volonté
politique de documenter les crimes les
crimes de guerre les horreurs et aussi
importantes quand tu crènes non
malheureusement il y a beaucoup de
financement sur l'Ukraine et je pense
qu'il en faudrait beaucoup ailleurs
c'est on travaille les ONG c'est ce
qu'on fait et je pense que c'est
important de le faire parce que ça
serait intéressant en fait de travailler
je me tourne ça sera le mot de la fin
pour Thomas au niveau mondial et qu'on
puisse documenter tout ça effectivement
avec ce sentiment anti-français un
largement alimenté par par Wagner en
Afrique en préparant cette émission j'ai
pu lire qu'au Mali il y a eu un faux
charnier à Gossi ont entièrement
fabriqués avec des cadavres enterrés
dans le désert par les commandos Wagner
c'est hallucinant et c'est la première
fois qu'on a utilisé des moyens
militaires pour déjouer une manœuvre
informationnelle c'est à dire on a vu la
chose arriver et on a dérouté un autre
drones
et montrer que comment des choses se il
faut rappeler enfin que dans certains
États africains Wagner intervient à la
demande des états locaux pour protéger
eux-mêmes leur régime et donc Wagner
aussi n'est qu'un symptôme d'un
affaiblissement des états vis-à-vis de
leur propre outil de sécurité et le défi
qui doivent recuer à cette société voilà
on espère que la volonté politique sera
au rendez-vous en français et au niveau
européen bien sûr on va s'arrêter là
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Etienne Klein dans une petite dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir le regard de Fanny
guinochet sur le plan anti fraude fiscal
de Gabriel Attal celui de Carole Barjon
sur le plan anti-abus des sites
pornographiques sur nos enfants et puis
cacher ce drapeau européen que je ne
saurais voir ce sera dans Bourbon
express avec Stéphanie des pierres mais
d'abord on va provoquer des
courts-circuits Étienne Klein c'est le
titre de votre essai chez Gallimard on
connaît votre goût pour les sujets
apparemment sans lien entre la physique
et la philosophie par exemple la vie des
idées nous dites-vous mérite qu'on la
décloisonne regardez c'est dans le sujet
de Maïté Frémont et puis on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Etienne Klein c'est
parce que vous incontournable
vulgarisateur scientifique provoquer une
nouvelle fois des étincelles voire des
coups de foudre d'encours circuit votre
nouvelle essai vous atomisez pas les
murs qui séparent certaines disciplines
mais vous créez des passerelles entre
les sciences dures et les sciences
humaines un livre court 205 pages qui
s'ouvrent avec l'histoire de votre frère
votre antiparticule allergique aux
équations dès qu'on dit que deux choses
sont absolument différentes on ne peut
pas s'empêcher de tenter de les
hiérarchiser on dit que a n'est pas du
tout la même chose que B et la question
qui vient est-ce que A est plus grand
que B ou meilleur que B ou est-ce que
c'est l'inverse et ça aboutit à une
hiérarchie dans le spectre
d'intelligence qui a des effets sur la
façon dont on oriente les cerveaux par
exemple si vous êtes soi-disant
intelligent on va vous conseiller de
devenir intellectuel ou scientifique et
si vous n'êtes pas on va vous demander
de faire une voix professionnelle
physique et philosophie réalité et
imagination hasard et destin dans ces 10
chapitres vous associez des éléments
souvent séparés dans la vie des idées le
binôme le plus atypique pour aborder la
notion du temps le voici celui de vos
deux idoles accrochées sur le mur de
votre chambre d'adolescent Einstein d'un
côté les Rolling Stones de l'autre
Etienne Klein bien difficile de vous
définir vous n'êtes ni physique si un ni
philosophe vous vous posez là où se
trouve la question du langage dites-vous
votre credo c'est d'exprimer avec des
mots ce que les physiciens disent avec
des équations et des expériences grâce à
vos ouvrages les sciences deviennent un
peu plus simples même pour ceux qui n'y
connaissent rien les sciences pour les
nuls quitte à créer des polémiques l'été
dernier vous postez sur les réseaux
sociaux une photo d'un chorizo avec pour
les jambes photos de l'étoile la plus
proche du Soleil un canular connu chez
les scientifiques pris pour une vérité
pour des milliers d'internautes alors
une question ce soir Étienne Klein
casser les barrières entre les
disciplines dès le plus jeune âge
permettrait-il de passer un peu moins
pour des andouilles
réponse c'était le clan en fait dans ce
livre je ne parle pas
d'interdisciplinarité je parle plutôt de
cohérence parce que l'interdiscipérité
qui suppose qu'on va mélanger les
disciplines
par exemple moi non je pense qu'il y a
des questions
se rapprocher voir ce que ça donne
regardez les éléments de langage par
exemple il y a des mots communs à
plusieurs disciplines est-ce qu'ils ont
le même sens dans toutes les disciplines
exemple le temps le temps moi j'ai
travaillé pendant des années sur le
temps avec des collègues les physiciens
parlent du temps les philosophes parlent
du temps donc il y a une première
question quand on a fait ce constat
c'est lorsqu'elle de la même manière
si la réponse à cette question est non
il parle de choses différentes il
faudrait les nommer par deux mots
différents et si parlent de la même
chose est-ce que ils en disent les mêmes
choses et la réponse est clairement NON
et donc à qui doit-on accorder du crédit
dès lors que toutes les thèses
cohabitent et c'est ce genre de
rencontre qui à mon avis peut aider
chacune des disciplines à progresser
notamment dans la façon qui est là de
s'expliquer pour le grand public parler
du temps philosophie et physique par
exemple quel autre exemple vous pourriez
nous donner de couple de disciplines qui
ont intérêt à se regarder pas forcément
à se mélanger mais par exemple on pense
à la science de l'inconscient certains
diront que c'est pas une science en tout
cas la psychologie et peut-être les
sciences cognitives là il y a un couple
qui fait oui
des instruments de physique les
neurosciences pour être villes le
cerveau par exemple utilise des
instruments qui ont été mis au point par
des physiciens donc il y a déjà un
apport disons techniques ensuite il y a
est-ce que la physique par exemple peut
aider à comprendre la vie où est-ce que
les lois de la biologie bénéfiques
bénéficient d'une sorte
d'extraterritorialité par rapport aux
lois physiques est-ce que les lois
biologiques s'il y en a s'ajoutent au
lois physiques ou est-ce qu'elles sont
in émanation à une certaine échelle des
lois qui existent un niveau plus profond
dans le domaine de la physique donc se
parler entre disciplines pour clarifier
aussi à mon avis c'est d'abord pour de
reconnaître pas forcément pour
collaborer et pour se connaître savoir
de quoi on parle quels sont les objets
d'études comparer les méthodologies
parce que toutes les sciences ne
travaillent pas la même façon un
sociologue ne travaille pas comme un
physicien théoricien qui ne travaille
pas comme un biologiste et donc c'est
déjà comprendre tout cela et ensuite
voir si certaines questions bien posées
réclament pour être traitées qu'on
sollicite plusieurs disciplines il
s'agit pas des rassembler pour le
plaisir de les rassembler il s'agit pas
de provoquer un mélange des genres pour
faire genre il s'agit de poser une
question bien précise et ensuite de voir
quelles sont les disciplines qui peuvent
t'aider à y répondre des passerelles
mais pas forcément la grande bouillie
d'une science des passerelles votre
premier chapitre vous le consacrez à
Pascal c'est votre frère décédé il y a 2
ans et demi virtuose de la clé à molette
et du fer à souder il aimait avant tout
réparer penser avec ses mains il a été
un peu brisé
notamment par l'école personne ne lui
avait dit qu'Einstein était aussi
bricoleur notamment pas moi je le
regrette plus que moi il est moyen un an
et demi et il avait besoin de
d'apprendre par corps pas en regardant
des équations il était
mal à l'aise avec les raisonnements
abstraits il les mettent touchés pour
comprendre d'ailleurs avant de réparer
des choses il en a beaucoup cassé
notamment mes jouets et fabriquer pour
comprendre comment
on a fabriqué un avion ensemble sous ses
ordres j'étais incapable dans ce domaine
de prendre des initiatives mais il avait
besoin oui de démonter les objets pour
les construire et il pouvait comprendre
le fonctionnement de moteur de toutes
sortes sans sans comprendre les
équations physiques qui permettent de
comprendre le fonctionnement il pouvait
comprendre n'empêche que cette
intelligence manuelle n'a pas été
reconnue c'est typiquement français vous
pensez à l'heure où Emmanuel Macron
essaye de relancer le chantier du lycée
professionnel j'ai passé une étude
suffisamment complète mais il me semble
que dans d'autres pays que je connais un
peu la Suisse l'Allemagne l'Angleterre
ça fonctionne pas du tout comme ça
pourquoi ça je sais pas je pense que
qu'est-ce qu'on a nous avec le manuel le
fer comme la capacité à accéder à
l'abstraction
alors qu'il y a une intelligence du
corps il y a une intelligence des mains
d'ailleurs toute ma intelligente est
pilotée par un esprit les guides
d'autres montagnes dont je parle ou les
facteurs d'orgue sont des gens qui ont
une intelligence tout à fait évidente
quand on les voit manipuler les
instruments qui les passionnent non j'ai
l'impression que que l'abstraction est
la mesure suprême de l'intelligence
qu'on soit d'ailleurs littéraire ou
scientifique il faut planer ça c'est le
symptôme que on pense bien mais je pense
que l'intelligence elle est plutôt
répartie selon un spectre continue qu'on
a tort de vouloir hiérarchiser encore
cette question de la hiérarchie Michel
Serres donc au cœur de cet ouvrage
philosophe des sciences vous inscrivez
dans dans ses pas grand vulgarisateur
aussi comme vous mais qui en même temps
connaissait l'impasse de la
vulgarisation toujours un trompe l'oeil
il a vulgarisation qui n'atteint pas son
but oui oui moi c'est le covid
l'expérience du covid qui m'a montré que
ce que croit je croyais être un succès
la vulgarisation en fait
quand je dis cela je biaise mon jugement
c'est à dire que la vulgarisation ça
marche auprès de ceux aux pretty ça
marche voilà qui s'intéresse qui se
délivre qui pose des questions ou bien
ces étudiants qu'on rencontre et qui
nous disent qu'ils ont choisi de faire
des sciences parce qu'ils ont lu
adolescents un livre de Michel Serres ou
dubery qu'est-ce qu'on a raté pendant le
covid alors qu'on a voulu expliquer en
mettant énormément d'épidémiologie sur
les plateaux pour que finalement le
complotisme les fake news explosent moi
je pense qu'on a vu l'occasion
historique de faire de la pédagogie
scientifique en disant voilà s'agissant
des traitements ce qu'est un essai en
double aveugle jour après jour parce que
les gens étaient inquiets ils avaient du
temps à passer devant la télévision il
voulait le comprendre et on pouvait leur
expliquer ce que nous savions est-ce que
nous savions ne pas savoir
l'extinction entre la science et la
recherche et puis surtout moi j'aurais
aimé entendre des gens sur les plateaux
qui disent nous nous savons que et nous
nous demandons si
c'est à dire qu'il montre que la science
est une entreprise collective et parfois
il faut dire nous ne savons pas c'est
parce que c'est pas parce que nous
disons que nous ne savons pas que nous
sommes moins savants
je ne sais pas on va dire c'est pas un
bon savant et on va le faire et qu'il
soit remplacé médiatiquement par
quelqu'un qui a réponse à tout et qui ne
doute jamais un mot sur un très joli
passage sur la joie chez Michel Serres
ce paradoxe de la joie malgré la
violence malgré la misère du monde
Michel Serres joyeux malgré tout oui un
philosophe qui a connu d'ailleurs Michel
Zack s'appelait Clément Rosset Clément
il y a quelques années qui parlait du
paradoxe de la joie en disant la joie
c'est la force majeure on n'est pas
joyeux parce qu'on a des raisons d'être
joyeux on est joyeux au contraire
prendre parce qu'on a conscience du
tragique
il me semble que Michel serre incarnait
cette sorte de paradoxe il était
toujours de bonne humeur toujours
qu'il a essayé de convertir
philosophiquement dans l'idée dominance
avec l'idée que l'humanité va finalement
lentement progresser et peut-être se
débarrasser de la violence et depuis que
ce livre le déluge informationnel qui a
toujours voulu expliquer comment ça
marchait aujourd'hui on utilise des
smartphones sans même se poser la
question ça reste inaccessible il l'a
connu ce déluge informationnel et
d'ailleurs au début il était très
enthousiaste il pensait que le numérique
les smartphones par exemple allaient
nous permettre d'avoir une encyclopédie
portative et puis il a vu qu'on est fait
dans les mêmes canaux de communication
circulent des connaissances mais aussi
des croyances des commentaires beaucoup
de commentaires des avis d'effect news
tout ça se mélange les statues
respectives de ces différents éléments
qui sont différents ont tendance à
s'amalgamer et ça je sais qu'à la fin de
la ville a donné une dernière interview
à Philosophie magazine sur ce sujet il
était plutôt
plutôt pessimiste et puis il y a
l'intelligence artificielle l'IA qui
commence à remplacer les journalistes
les comptables les secrétaires et j'en
passe les étudiants même qui recouvrent
à chat Tipiti pour leur exposé les
algorithmes ils vont détrôner à votre
avis notre cerveau c'est à mon avis ça
dépend encore de nous c'est d'ailleurs
finalement puisque les machines parlent
comme nous en langage naturel parfois
elles écrivent mieux que nous des
dissertations des articles quel rôle
devons-nous avoir dans l'expression de
notre parole qu'est-ce que c'est que une
parole authentiquement humaine par
rapport à une machine comme tchadibi je
sais pas si vous avez déjà lu des
dissertations de tiadibilité c'est lisse
il y a pas d'idées fulgurante il y a pas
d'invention de concept tchat Jupiter
raconte des choses qui ont déjà été
racontées par les données qui l'ont été
livrées pour pour s'éduquer lui-même et
donc les capacités de d'esprit critique
d'invention de concept ça reste une
démonstration
le mot intelligence dans l'intelligence
artificielle quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle c'est le mot
anglais
le traitement de la formation
l'intelligence au sens français du terme
c'est aussi la capacité à poser des
questions contrefactuelles c'est
l'esprit critique donc on a mal nommé en
fait oui les choses donc pour l'instant
l'intelligence artificielle est
extrêmement bête ça va poser quand même
des questions existentielles on est armé
à votre avis moi je pense qu'il est
temps de vraiment réfléchir à ce qu'on
veut voilà il y a un paradoxe qui avait
été nommé par Monsieur qui s'appelle
mort avec dans les années 1990 qui
disait en gros plus une tâche est facile
à utiliser par un humain plus elle sera
difficile à exécuter par une machine ou
un robot il donnait l’exemple de
coiffeur un coiffeur pour l'instant les
coiffeurs ne sont pas menacés par les
robots ils peuvent les robots peuvent
coiffer enfin mettre la boule à zéro
mais pas faire une coupe
harmonieuse et il donnait l’exemple de
la reconnaissance faciale et là il s'est
trompé les machines font de la
reconnaissance faciale de façon très
efficace et donc la question est quels
sont les décisions que nous acceptons de
déléguer à des machines quelles sont les
tâches que nous acceptons à déléguer à
des robots
merci beaucoup ça s'appelle cours
circuit au pluriel ça se picore puisque
les chapitres sont indépendants les uns
des autres ce qui aiment les Rolling
Stones et Albert Einstein c'est le même
seront Einstein c'est une pierre Stone
c'est des pierres et voilà un
court-circuit de plus c'est chez
Gallimard et c'est passionnant vous
restez avec moi Étienne Klein les
affranchis à présent ils vont vous faire
réagir on est d'accueille tout de suite
l'économie avec Fanny guinochet de
France Info ce soir la lutte finale sur
la fraude fiscale la société la
politique avec Carole Barjon de lobbs ce
soir la fin de l'impunité ou pas pour
les sites pornos et puis bonsoir à vous
mesdames on commence comme chaque soir
par le bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir par Stéphanie
Despierre bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir une
histoire de drapeau ce soir exactement
le député Renaissance Mathieu Lefebvre
veut rendre obligatoire l'accrochage du
drapeau français et du drapeau européen
sur chaque mairie alors aujourd'hui en
fait ce n'est obligatoire que dans les
salles de classe dans les écoles et dans
les collèges la proposition de loi du
député étant débat depuis à 19h dans
l'hémicycle alors le camp présidentiel
est celle de poser le débat en ces
termes-là pour ou contre l'Europe votre
projet c'est un frexit masqué à lancer
le député Renaissance aux insoumis de
son côté la France insoumise dénonce
justement ce débat binaire que vous
voulez imposer je cite avec vos gros
sabots alors la proposition de loi
peut-elle être adoptée et bien en
commission elle a été rejetée
Renaissance n'a même pas pu compter sur
le soutien de son allié du MoDem qui
s'était abstenu et à quelques heures du
vote tout à l'heure les troupes de
François Bayrou et restaient plus que
sceptiques on sent que cette proposition
de loi vous agace un peu vous vous
semblez estimez que on y passe trop de
temps pourquoi oui alors je pense qu'on
y passe trop de temps au rapport et en
rapport aux préoccupations des qu'on les
Français en ce moment ils ont des
préoccupations de pouvoir d'achat ils
ont des préoccupations autour de leur
travail mais on ne pourra pas voter
contre le drapeau européen
difficile en effet pour les députés
modem très pro-européens de voter contre
en cette journée vous le savez de
l'Europe niveau symbole ça ne ferait pas
joli mais seront-ils vraiment nombreux
dans l'hémicycle certains décident-ils
finalement de s'abstenir on le verra
dans la soirée les insoumis eux ne
voteront pas c'est clair même si leur
position sur l'Europe est diamétralement
opposée à celle du modèle il questionne
comme l'utilité de ce texte c'est un
sujet de diversion et quand les Français
apprennent que on est en train de parler
du drapeau européen plutôt que de parler
de la question du pouvoir d'achat des
salaires de l'inflation de la retraite à
60 ans et non pas 64 ou bien encore de
la Sixième République bien les Français
se disent mais que font nos députés en
fait c'est la question pavoisée
obligatoirement le de la drapeau
européen dans chaque mairie qui pose
débat oui Myriam ce week-end chez nos
confrères de France Info maintenant
Aubry une euro député insoumise à même
carrément déclaré que le drapeau
européen était une forfaiture
démocratique carrément déclaration à
tout en nuances en référence au nom à la
Constitution européenne des Français en
2005 alors à cet argument et à celui de
l'inutilité le député Renaissance
Mathieu Lefebvre rétorque la politique
s’est aussi une affaire de symbole
à quoi sert cette proposition loi sur le
drapeau européen et le drapeau français
alors que même vous alliez du MoDem
commence à dire ça ne sert à rien ça ne
sert à rien affirmer des valeurs dans un
jour éminemment symbolique on est le 9
mai la Journée de l'Europe nous on verra
affirmer notre attachement à la fois à
notre drapeau français il y a aucune
obligation légale aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoiser sur les mairies mais aussi à la
construction européenne dans le contexte
à la fois de brexit et de guerre en
Ukraine une député européenne la France
insoumise parle de forfaiture
démocratique à propos du drapeau
européen qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
je pense qu'il fallait oser quand on est
soi-même parlementaire européen élu du
suffrage universel européen parlait de
forfaiture à propos du drapeau européen
le fer à 8 mai par ailleurs dans un jour
où le Président Zelinski montre la photo
du drapeau européen aux côtés du drapeau
ukrainien
s'il ne fait le pas le plein des voix du
côté du MoDem et de renaissance Mathieu
Lefebvre risque d'avoir du mal à faire
voter sa proposition de loi vous l'avez
compris les insoumis sont contre mais
les républicains et le rassemblement
national aussi les écologistes et les
socialistes voteront pour alors avant
même le début des débats certains
députés Renaissance se demandaient déjà
ce qu'ils étaient allés faire dans cette
galère en prenant le risque d'être battu
sur une proposition somme toute assez
secondaire alors victoire ou défaite on
en aura la réponse dans la soirée oui
évidemment rendez-vous sur LCP.fr nos
équipes suivent ce vote minute par
minute qu'elle regarde vous portez sur
ce débat était là à mon avis n'a aucune
importance mais si j'étais député je
voterai oui pour le drapeau européen oui
j'ai visité pas très longtemps le Royal
Alberto Einstein a donné sa dernière
conférence en Europe le 3 octobre 1933
avant de quitter l'Europe pour toujours
il parle d'Hitler il parle de la
situation européenne qu'il faut défendre
et donc cette conception là me parle et
je vois pas trop et là parler de
forfaiture par exemple
ça doit pas être possible allez on
enchaîne avec vous fan et Gabriel Attal
le ministre du Budget a donc présenté un
plan contre la fraude fiscale il cible
les ultra-riches qui échappent à l'impôt
et oui il y en a en France et tout ça
pour ramener un maximum d'argent dans
les caisses de l'État oui ça rapporte
actuellement 14 milliards d'euros la
fraude fiscale tout compris c'est-à-dire
à la fois les pénalités les amendes mais
aussi le recouvrement c'est à dire ce
que on n'a pas payé alors attention on
parle bien de fraude et pas
d'optimisation fiscale qui est légale et
là alors effectivement ça pose
moralement en question mais on est dans
la légalité et c'est essayer de faire
tout ce qui est possible pour échapper
un maximum à l'impôt alors la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale c'est important
mais attention prévient Bruno Le Maire
tout de même le ministre de l'Économie
ça ne réglera pas tous les problèmes si
on fait rentrer cet argent on ne
couvrira pas toutes les dépenses de la
France mais Gabriel Attal prévient
notamment les gros il dit chaque fraude
est grave mais celle des plus puissants
est impardonnable et il promet de
renforcer les contrôles fiscaux sur les
plus gros patrimoines ces contrôles
devraient augmenter de 25%. ah oui c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal alors pourquoi ça
vient comme maintenant ce que vous
pouvez pas le faire avant il faudrait
pas croire qu'on est rien fait et que
l'État ne fasse rien Bercy par exemple
à renforcer ses contrôles notamment
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et
aux réseaux sociaux il y a pas si
longtemps on a aussi fait sauter le
verrou de Bercy je rentre pas dans les
tailles mais c'est un dispositif qui
permettait plutôt au gros au plus
fortuné qui était pris la main dans le
sac de s'arranger avec le fisc et puis
du côté des entreprises par exemple
l'année dernière McDo a payé quand même
office un milliard trois soit une
bigamante pour éviter d'être traîné
devant les tribunaux au sujet d'un
dossier de fraude fiscale alors Gabriel
Attal s'adresse au classe moyenne là en
disant on va faire payer
plus gros fraudeur vous voyez on agit
alors côté sanction on verra en tout cas
si c'est dissuasif ou pas parce que le
ministre des comptes publics promettent
des pertes de crédit d'impôts si jamais
vous faites prendre d'être déchu du
droit de vote ou même des travaux
d'intérêt général le gros fraudeur par
exemple ira repeindre les murs des
centres des impôts j'ai entendu on
attend les images
alors il y a un message politique
évidemment bien évidemment alors Gabriel
Attal s'adresse notamment au classement
moyenne
électorat d'Emmanuel Macron entre deux
mais aussi du côté de l'extrême droite
du côté de Marine Le Pen puisqu'on sait
que le RN a souvent fait de la lutte
contre la fraude sociale son cheval de
bataille mais aussi la nuque qui parle
beaucoup d'évasion fiscale et de de
multinationales qui échappent à l'impôt
le gouvernement
prévoit aussi un deuxième volet de son
plan mais cette fois-ci qui concernerait
plutôt la fraude sociale tout ce qui est
cot aide sociale que peuvent toucher une
autre esprit là aussi le message est
évidemment politique on va suivre ça de
très près on enchaîne avec vous Carole
vous avez choisi de nous parler des
enfants et des sites pornos ce soir oui
parce qu'une fois n'est pas coutume on
nous annonce une bonne nouvelle le
gouvernement à l'intention de s'attaquer
sérieusement au plateformes
pornographiques qui ne vérifie pas l'âge
de leurs utilisateurs et qui sont donc
facilement accessibles aux enfants il
faut savoir qu'environ 2 millions
d'enfants accèdent à des sites porno
chaque mois alors que ce sont évidemment
des sites réservés aux adultes comme la
force justement dit ce matin le ministre
en charge du numérique Jean-Noël
Barrault les enfants sont les grandes
victimes de la société numérique cette
société est en effet fondée sur la
liberté d'abord la liberté sans
contrainte sur le web en quelque sorte
il est interdit d'interdire
or on sait depuis des années et tous les
pédopsychiatres et les psy alerté
là-dessus que les images porno ont des
conséquences absolument désastreuses sur
le développement affectif des enfants et
bien entendu sur leur apprentissage de
la sexualité il était donc grand temps
de faire le ménage dans ce domaine
d'autant que Manuel Macron l'avait
promis il y a déjà 4 ans que j'aime
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce qui
est prévu donc pour protéger le ministre
veut donner à l'arcom donc l'autorité de
régulation de l'audiovisuel et du
numérique le pouvoir de bloquer l'accès
au site qui ne respecte pas l'obligation
de vérifier l'âge de leurs utilisateurs
la loi les oblige en effet à le faire
depuis 2020 avant il suffisait
simplement de déclarer qu'on était
majeur si le blocage des accès au site
ne suffisaient pas l'arcom pourrait
aussi procéder au déréférencesment de
ces sites pornos sur les moteurs de
recherche et ce sans passer par
l'intermédiaire d'un juge
enfin le ministre prévoit d'instaurer
une amende de 4% de leur chiffre
d'affaires à ces sites qu'il qualifie de
mercenaires cupides et irresponsable qui
place le trafic le profit et les
recettes publicitaires au-dessus de la
santé de nos enfants on ne saurait mieux
dire alors même question que fait
pourquoi on l'a pas fait plus tôt et ben
c'est le problème c'est que c'est
sanctions sont assez difficiles à
appliquer car la loi de 2020 ne précise
pas les modalités de vérification de
l'âge des utilisateurs et c'est le
prétexte dont ce sont ces il est grand
géants du porno pour contester cette
obligation en justice
enfin le ministre veut s'appuyer sur les
agents de l'arcom dont certains seront
assermentés pour procéder au contrôle
mais l'arcom combien de divisions comme
on le sait le progrès le problème pardon
des démocraties occidentales libérales
c'est la question du contrôle et qui dit
contrôle dit effectivement pour les
effectuer évidemment j'espère pour
joindre le barreau qui leur a autant de
chances que Gabriel Attal son ministre
collègue du budget qui se targue d'avoir
1500 effectifs supplémentaires pour
lutter contre la grande fraude fiscale
parce que si ce n'est pas le cas pour
Jean-Noël Barrault je crains que la
protection des enfants face au porno ne
demeurent un vœu pieux ça passera
peut-être par l'intelligence
artificielle en tout cas la régulation
posait des limites réfléchir au cadre ça
revient dans tous les sujets Etienne
Klein la question je sais pas si on a le
temps mais comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour contrôler l'âge de quelqu'un qui
regarde une plateforme avec une
obligation de contraintes sous la
houlette de l'arkum c'est ça l'idée
vous voulez dire que par exemple un
adulte accède au site et qui peut avoir
des enfants autour avec lui et ça c'est
plus bonne question allez Jean-Noël
Barrault l'invitation est lancée au
ministre des sujets numériques merci les
amis les affranchis à très vite et Merci
à VOUS Etienne Klein d'être venu sur le
plateau de LCP c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien bien sûr très belle
soirée et à demain
[Musique]